yeah oh and welcome to this video this
is a blitz video right yeah I haven't
done one of those for a long while but I
felt like doing some again and yeah
there's some reasons for that one reason
is that just look right ok and one
reason is that the strength of opponents
on Leach has really has gone up quite a
bit you really have a challenge nowadays
if you play your blitz and you can play
3+2 quite conveniently you get opponents
and this is what I want to do I don't
want to play 5-0 or that much I really
feel three plus two is much better and
also in terms of doing them I'm doing
commentary um yeah let's see I don't
know if I will make it ready regular
feature of the channel again maybe do
that one thing that was a little bit of
a problem with the streaming that I did
earlier this year set it always though
show Stone took took ages to do I
already like hours and hours and it did
mean it is fun but it's just too long in
some cases for me and probably just
recording the short videos is easier
also I got many requests why don't you
do some Blitz videos again there's some
yeah some people really prefer the
shorter 1015 minute videos that you
maybe can watch like breakfast or
whatever some people told me that they
watch it yeah when they em when they
basically finish the day and instead of
like reading a book or a magazine
article or so they they have a look at
the videos or one one particular blitz
video per day ok let's talk a bit about
this game I'm playing
Blackheart be here on Lee chess and I've
got a position that feels a little bit
difficult from black already I feel the
night on aged six looks a bit odd and
six pawn is weak so I'm trying to make
use of that Bishop f4 has a couple of
ideas one is to bolster e5 in case of an
f6 move and also he has to worry about
g4 Queen d2 that would trap his Knight
of course I want to want to clear the C
1 square for the rook
yeah b3 maybe also came into
consideration yeah this is one of those
moments where you can think wait
actually if I do this he cannot go c5
yeah
c5 Quincy one will lose the pawn so he
cannot go c5 that's important yeah
Quincy when I'm attacking the knight and
I always forget that we go here like I
can draw during the game only chess the
Quincy one is the key idea if c5 is
played yeah he wants to really get the
Xin but yeah Queen Queen d2 I'm not sure
even g4s is really a move I mean he
almost has to go King g8 after that to
make to give a little bit of room for
the for the night I'm not sure g4 King
h8 22 not g8 it does not lead to
anything concrete as far as I can see
I can't still do that I mean one point
is that it should be three is also
possible then without being arrest by
9f5 so that Bishop III will stop c5 as
long as he cannot play c5 and get rid of
his pawn I'm eternity better hmm
why is he thinking I was thinking that
King h8 is totally mandatory okay maybe
King f8 but it looks a bit odd yeah and
his art yeah no it no it plays it yeah
so Queen d2 is kind of useful anyway so
let's do it take this temple and now
okay if I go look C 1 C 5 takes rook
takes Bishop e3 is is a way to also stop
C 5 so I don't have to play Bishop b3
immediately okay so he's on that square
but Knight g5 now comes into
consideration looking at f7 maybe do
this first yeah
again stopping c5 this is 3 plus 2 so I
thought I was stopping it
that was the point and I should win some
chunk of material or I said D for D for
Bishop takes rook t5 but should be 6
roopd - yeah indeed let this work hmm
that's a bit odd if I take this if I
take c5 he takes is 3 I take b6 hmm wait
BC v te 3 C takes b6 it takes T to be 7
huh does not win it's really really
remarkable ok Bishop takes rook T 5 but
should be 6 rooted to 92-86 also does
not win that's really a bit crazy really
odd
not sure what's best I mean maybe this
one so that I have the that I have the
c5 pawn as the SD extra pawn little bit
difficult at this moment to assess boobs
that's not blunder the Queen I came I
wanted to do this get night b5 into the
into this sometimes gotcha oh it does
not stop it maybe wanted to go away six
and it was a mouse lip almost looked
like a mouse lip okay still not a super
easy win or something
I don't see a direct way to win I will
do a witness not that it is hard to
believe
let's see a win amazing how is that
possible even okay
finally sorry ah okay set working you
with an L as a sport yeah I think it's
it's okay alright you see that point
it's a bit of a first first-time thing
yet and so I don't know if everything
works out fine for you to see so we have
the analysis board here
it was the c3 line against
hyperaccelerated dragon I think a line
that's pretty good for Wyatt nothing of
course it's not refuting g6 or anything
but it's it's kind of came for white a
little bit better I guess I actually
believe that black him I should go d5 he
himself and not a play Bishop g7 I think
that this is already a little bit better
for white it's not I don't think black
an equaliser anymore I mean nothing
terrible but just objectively I think
you should go d5 before the issue one
one issue is simply the structure which
is it's just not noise I think I should
have played differently here maybe b3 I
think b3 was what I recommended in my
evo kibbutzim to repertoire but yeah
Bishop g5 is given here by the engine as
an as a move certainly a f6 is not
possible and you have to be a bit
cautious like if you go here you're
already blundered the night and it has
no squares oops
yeah forget
yeah that's no squares okay Bishop f4 I
mean that was not bad but maybe not the
absolutely most forceful way to play b3
Rock FC 8 g4 yeah that basically forced
King ajd I didn't really see an
alternative and then we arrived here at
the mazing I'm it's amazing that has
thoughts if I had stopped and it seems
it is stopped
what did I do wrong take take and now
hmm the engine gives before until I had
a clearer winner since know what I did
was actually best I mean okay I wasn't
really doubting that I should be winning
here but it was still was still a little
bit a little bit tricky rookie one group
t6 supposed to be better yeah you know
possible I mean in the context of a
blitz game I think what I did is is okay
okay Queen h6 is indeed a lot better
yeah that that's a lot better just going
for this no now that that I should've
played that I really should have in g7
me either
I really think that was a mouse slipping
I wanted to go way 600 route before
already was okay for black human that's
remarkable
yeah it's already not that easy here I
mean I'm not happy in this particular
position that g4 is played it's not it's
a bit of a weakness and I don't have a
clear way to get the C pawn forward
before what is the idea
26 or something and the apron is just
hanging a 5 was definitely some sort of
small slip I mean I mean it was a
mistake let's put it like that
okay 96 is not difficult to see but it
was too difficult for me yeah a bit
rusty and I'm definitely a bit rusty in
terms of blitz haven't played much blitz
on line I mean okay it is a totally
winning position when you can cannot
really spoil it didn't do something like
spoiling it when he's got 95 I really
played this terribly and 90 X b5 I also
didn't see okay when he had no time but
still I could could have seen like at
least a little bit of stuff I saw that
that he cannot take off colander that I
did see but yeah there was a shaky game
to say the least and ultimately he
faltered moment that I'm winning with no
time on the clock
yeah not the most precise game ever I
hope you enjoyed the return of the Blitz
games though and yeah
there will be more posted thanks for
watching